this room is a safety net called the
base it's for kids at dunraven school in
south london
who are at risk of dropping out i'm here
because
i was struggling to go to school and i
was out of lessons a lot
jack started going absent from school
because like many he struggled with
adjusting from primary to secondary
he preferred lockdown classes i like
that i could
i find doing the work at home i'm just
sitting on my computer doing it
i think it's when i'm there in real life
i start getting that stressed out and
anxious
zarlene says but for the base she may
not be here
she's come to speak to the support team
because she found coming back to school
overwhelming and has had panic attacks
being
forced to stay at home 24 7.
it's kind of flared up my anxiety
because you're basically chopped
by yourself all the time
with no one to really distract you the
schools noticed that children from
disadvantaged backgrounds are least
likely to attend regularly since
lockdown
and parents give a range of reasons the
explanations that are given for example
it's they're really struggling to get
students out of bed and to see the
purpose they've lost a sense of purpose
i think another thing with that is that
they have been staying up very very late
they've got into this
pattern of being so much on phones on
their phones
or game playing with others with other
people that's been their form of contact
nationally post lockdown school
attendance levels look okay but the
enthusiasm of some to get back to class
has masked the drop-off of others much
has been anecdotal but a new study by
think tank social finance
of 17 000 pupils in cheshire west and
chester
has found a 25 percent increase in
persistently absent
children in the first term of the
academic year and most of them
from poorer backgrounds the key concerns
that we've found is that children who
are persistently absent
are the children we should probably be
most worried about these are the
children that are accessing free school
meals
that have contact with social care or
have got a special educational need
these children are invisible and we need
to make them visible
london schools in poorer areas are so
concerned that they're forming a new
group of heads
called reconnect london to pool ideas on
how to tackle the problem
i think at heart it has to be about the
relationships
that the young people feel they have
with adults trusted adults in school and
i think if those relationships exist
if the adults in school know how to
develop those relationships and engage
with those young people
you've got a much better chance of
getting them in it's always been
children from disadvantaged backgrounds
who are more likely to skip
school but what this report shows is
that that problem has become
more pronounced lockdown has widened the
attendance gap
and it's those kids on the fringes who
are falling
further away the reasons are complex
saskia desperately wanted to go back to
school i've lost my identity
because i haven't been very social she's
been absent from october last year to
april
because her mother was shielding with
cancer and i'm not very good at
communicating my feelings
so my mum couldn't really help me in
that sense
because i just shut down report authors
say the government shouldn't just focus
on everyone catching up but also
supporting those at risk
of falling out of education altogether
jason farrell sky news